-Performing
"Everything's Electric"
from his upcoming album,
"C'mon You Know,"
here's Liam Gallagher!
[ Cheering and applause ]
♪♪
-♪ The city is burning ♪
♪ Sinking ships in the ocean ♪
♪ With a head full
of dreams at night ♪
♪ Sorrow's written
the story of life ♪
♪ Ain't nothing to do, but ♪
♪ I was digging for gold dust ♪
♪ I see the shame
in your eyes this time ♪
♪ And no, baby,
it's cold inside ♪
♪♪
♪ Your fake humble called out,
got you tongue-tied ♪
♪ Your best chance at success
got ya denied ♪
♪ No ♪
♪ You thought I wouldn't know? ♪
♪ I don't hate you ♪
♪ But I despise that feeling ♪
♪ There's nothing
left for me here ♪
♪ You won't know
if you don't go ♪
♪ Superficial feelings ♪
♪ It's hard to take it easy ♪
♪ Underneath the red sun ♪
♪ Everything's electric ♪
♪♪
♪ Tell me, what do you love? ♪
♪ And would you
let it kill you? ♪
♪ With a head full
of dreams at night ♪
♪ Sorrow's written
the story of life ♪
♪ And the higher that we go ♪
♪ And the longer
that we can fly ♪
♪ I never knew what you wanted ♪
♪ So I gave you everything ♪
♪♪
♪ Your life's short
and most days are long now ♪
♪ Chain of missing links
is all that's left now, so ♪
♪ You gotta let it go ♪
♪ I don't hate you ♪
♪ But I despise that feeling ♪
♪ There's nothing
left for me here ♪
♪ You won't know
if you don't go ♪
♪ Superficial feelings ♪
♪ It's hard to take it easy ♪
♪ Underneath the red sun ♪
♪ Everything's electric ♪
♪♪
♪ I don't hate you ♪
♪ But I despise that feeling ♪
♪ There's nothing
left for me here ♪
♪ You won't know
if you don't go ♪
♪ Superficial feelings ♪
♪ It's hard to take it easy ♪
♪ Underneath the red sun ♪
♪ Everything's electric ♪
♪♪
[ Cheering and applause ]